[Music]
rizza rizza is your name but you have so
many nicknames and i i just these are
just a few okay and i want to just run
through them real fast because you have
amazing nicknames prince rakim the
scientist bobby steele prince dynamite
resurrector the avid bobby digital
prince delight ruler zig zag zig ala
these are great nicknames
[Applause]
it's like you have those and i have coco
i got screwed in the nickname department
no you got a cool name man no you i call
you colin the barbarian of comedy
barbarian of oh
but you know what it is it's like um you
know many people got many personalities
yeah i mean so i've learned to identify
that personality and give it a name i
understand so these each each one of
these uh each one of these nicknames
comes with its own person if i was bobby
stills right now son i'd be like yo cody
man it's like this try to keep it real
with your boy you know but right now i'm
not bobby stills
what about
who's ruler zig zag zig allah what's he
like really that's when i get very very
spiritual actually you know i mean we
start talking about you know world peace
and making this world a better place you
know i mean that's when i go internal
you know i mean that wasn't that number
seven i understand i understand
you should be ruler zigzag zaga ola when
you go to starbucks the next time so
they have to say it when they get there
[Applause]
that's me you know what
i'm doing that tomorrow
that's a great idea did you come up with
these nicknames yourself or did you get
are you given nicknames do people ever
say to you i've got one for you yeah
well sometimes i make them up but
sometimes i got buddies in the
neighborhood that walk up and they like
they just hook you up with a name kid
yeah yeah that's great i want to go talk
to these guys
[Music]
it's like the abbott the abbott is
something that i got from all the wu
chang brothers you know method man and
rayquan they was like yo you're the
abbott and the abbott is like in the
shaolin temple there's like the ball
head monk who's the most wisest yeah and
uh ben i was considered the most wisest
guy in my crew at the time it was like
you're the abbott we're going to follow
you abby whatever you want to go and i
became the abbott of wu-tang clan that's
very cool i i love this concept i want
i would like i really like the idea of
having uh you know nicknames for each
different mood
like you know when i'm paranoid or you
know
self-hating or self-loathing or i don't
like myself ko nizzle
you have an app coming out rizz's world
is this out or is it coming out oh no
there is the world app is out right now
it's available um it's an application
you go on uh your iphone right now for
through itunes you can download that
into your phone and it's an app to play
chess is that right yeah what's the app
of many things but it does include chess
and uh the reason why i put chess in my
applications because growing up in my
neighborhood we always never think
before we do so you know teenage
pregnancy or a lot of violence because
we're not very analytical right and
chess to me teaches analytical skills
and so i advise chess for children so
you could think before you make a move
forecast your life four cash a day you
know i think that's better for our
country if you take a look at um in the
russians all the great world champions
is mostly russian right because they
teach chess in school
i think chess in school music and school
and all the arts we kind of keep putting
that inside our schools because it gives
us a better chance
it's a great
way to teach people to think
you uh you are interested in is this
right you want to play jay-z because
jay-z plays his plays chess doesn't he
oh yeah he does play athlete already
played his vertical chest so now i
haven't played that yet but i'm looking
forward to it you know and the joker's
my man i love jay-z but i would love to
get on the chess board with him maybe we
get don king to promote it
pay-per-view
yes